five people have been killed after a
Russian missile struck the Eastern
Ukrainian city of sloviansk Ukrainian
officials confirmed that 21 people were
also injured in the strike which damaged
10 apartment buildings it comes as
Ukrainian troops are forced to withdraw
from parts of back mode as the battle
for the city rages on well I'm joined in
the studio now by our military analyst
retired Air Vice Marshal Sean Bell their
high again Sean tell us more about this
missile strike overnight the Russian
attacks have continued but particularly
at sloviansk the Russian just shown here
the Russian missiles attacked hit Flats
houses and cars the casualty figures
keep Rising so it's nine killed so far
21 injured but when we see the pictures
of some of the devastation we fully
expect those figures to increase now it
could be in the Russians targeting the
Bak mooch resupply routes which run from
sovietansk but actually what that what
looks increasing likely for a military
perspective is the Russians are looking
Beyond back moot what happens after back
moot uh slavion slovians and Crema torsk
are the two probable targets further
which is all consistent with Russia's
and Putin's special military operation
which is to seize the whole of the
donbass there are some wires coming to
us saying that the Wagner group is
claiming to have taken
what is the latest uh We've seem to have
been reporting about Mac move for ages
over nine months now the fierce fighting
in back moot a grinding War of Attrition
which largely fell into a bit of a
stalemate but it does look like the
Russian military in Nevada military
group are now working together rather
than against each other if you remember
sometime the bakmuta river which was
here natural barrier we had the Russians
on the East uh ukrainians on the west
but actually over the last few weeks the
Russians have gained momentum they've
gained a foothold and are now pushing
further further west and now seems to
control about three quarters of the city
it's also worth noting the 504 with the
road that runs down towards you as a
resupply route for Ukraine but also it's
their line of Escape it's becoming
increasingly under pressure and it does
look now as you said in the last 24
hours even more advances it's looking
increasing likely that bakmuta will fall
in the coming days or weeks and provide
President Putin one of the rare
successes on the battlefield but this
has been at a huge cost of casualties of
conservative estimates at least 30 000
Russian casualties and mass of Ukrainian
casualties as well plus Devastation if
this was actually part of Putin's
liberation of Ukraine if you look up
back moot now the devastation reached it
hardly looks like a city that's been
liberated
um it appears as though President Putin
is worried about resources and Russian
forces on the ground he's signed a bill
hasn't he to stop people dodging
military service he has the Russians
have had a real problem with troops
mainly because they keep using them in
such a bad way 20th century tactics just
keep waves upon waves of people running
at machine guns which is not effective
highly attritional they immobilize 300
000 at the tail end of last year but
they've consumed most of those they
desperately need more and President
Putin will judge that having another
round of mobilization almost certainly
won't play well in Russian Society the
Wagner military group on the yevgeni
pregozin over the far side there has
been effective but with that
Effectiveness has been a rising in
influence and he's become a bit of a
political threat now to Putin so that's
not not the way forward Russia has tried
to get more volunteers involved but
those peers Russian Society is not keen
on joining there's been less than 10
take up on those positions and as you
say Putin's been trying to tighten the
loopholes about how you recruit people
um because it used to be done where you
had to hand the papers to people so
whenever they saw them coming down the
path they didn't open the front door or
they'd or they kept out the way now it's
being electronically handled so that
people can't avoid that and there's also
interestingly Putin's looking to
generate more private military companies
but this time under the direct control
of the army but all of this will
generate more people the challenge
they've got is that you need experienced
boats that are well trained and
unfortunately what's evidence at the
moment is this lack of training means
that people aren't following the law of
armed conflicts or the Geneva Convention
that Putin has signed up to and that's
why we're seeing so many atrocities
things like the beheading a real problem
going forward for President Putin he's
struggling to generate the quantity of
sold just and absolutely failing to
deliver the quality